في اخر الانباء افاد مراسل الجزيره باصابه
عدد من الفلسطينيين بجروح جراء قصف
استراليني استهدف المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه
خان يونس جنوبيه قطاع غزه واعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه استهدف خليه لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي كانت تستعد لقصف صخف صاروخي من
قطاع غزه وبحسب مراسل الجزيره فان هناك
اصابات نجمت عن القصف الاسرائيلي
اذا نذكر مره اخرى بهذه الاخبار العاجله
التي تظهر على شاشتنا الان لانه هنالك
اصابات نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي لشرق خان
يونس اسرائيل الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه
صدف خليه كانت تستعد لاطلاق صواريخ وهي
خليه تابعه للسرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي هذه هذا التطور
الذي حدث اليوم في خان يونس في غزه ياتي
بعد
في اليوم الثاني للاغتيال الاسرائيلي
اغتيال اسرائيل لثلاثه من قاره حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي